natalie have you been
with anyone
no dates no with anyone
hanging out with anybody
oh this girl just with girls who was the
guy you were with in new orleans jovi
wasn't mike what
see audacity natalie brought a new man
to dinner when she visited yara and jovi
in new orleans and i guess she thought
they wouldn't tell at the tell-all but
they did and she was with a friend yara
and jovi had no problem outing her ask
her if they could together but
that was no clear answer plus one camera
calm down
it wouldn't be a tell-all if angela
didn't go off
these brand new beats what was all these
numbers how do you like that now she
popped out those new things
show my husband
during a heated argument with michael
and his aunt which led to her walking
offset we'll get into what caused the
breakdown and the nudity in just a few
but speaking of angela tiffany might
need to seek her out for some advice
yeah i'm excited it's been a long
process she announced that she's about
to make a major life change i just know
with everything that's going on in my
life right now this is like the right
step for me
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisa you want
bumps
part one of happily ever after season
eight tell all did not disappoint but i
will warn you right now if you're
already over natalie's behavior i'm sick
of hearing her be the victim man what
we're about to talk about will probably
frustrate you even more so
prepare yourselves i'm nervous because
i'm gonna face mike
some part of me does misses him
uh and it's hard because i don't know
what he feels i haven't seen her in
months
ready for the pain
show then that's what it is as expected
natalie and mike arrived at the tell-all
separately and when they got on set they
revealed that they are not together
except for maybe on paper
natalie what is the relationship how do
you describe the relationship no
relationship
also
fun fact right after that natalie shared
that she now lives in florida i'm not in
washington anymore you're not in
washington no i'm in florida yes after
she left michael's house to go stay with
her friend juliana
she moved across the country from
washington to florida
i just want you to sit with that florida
mike you knew
natalie was she told me she told me she
moved to florida i don't know where she
lives in florida or who she's staying
with keep in mind what mike said about
how he doesn't know where she lives in
florida or who she's staying with
because there's a moment coming up that
will have your mouth on the floor
but before we get into that
natalie went on to explain why she left
mike in the first place basically saying
that he was working too much and when he
would finally get home he would be tired
and he told me that she's in work
i never said that okay he never said it
to me i'm sorry it's my fault okay i
work really hard to support us
unfortunately covet hit and i lost all
my employees and yes i run the company
and
most of my employees had kids they all
had to quit
i don't think mike is a problem over
here preach andre
i don't think so either
natalie wanted this marriage so bad
which is supposed to be for better or
for worse
but it sounds like the moment something
happened with her husband that he
couldn't even control
she gave up on it and walked away
now don't get me wrong i am not
complaining that they are no longer
together that's probably for the best
but the fact that she said she
ultimately left because he had to work
overtime during the height of the
pandemic i don't like working all these
hours just sounds like she wasn't here
for him in the first place
she wanted to be out and about when i
came here it was total disaster i
couldn't do anything and i went crazy in
the wood
i have my rights to move even to the
moon i came here confident girl what
i've been through it brought me to
feeling miserable going on 20
putting 20 pounds and feeling
anniversary terrible as someone who has
been on a self-worth journey of my own
you get to a certain age where feeling
unworthy is nobody's fault but yours
that has nothing to do with mike and
look maybe it's best that she moved i'm
all about doing what's right for you but
in that process don't try to paint
somebody else as a bad guy
just take full responsibility and say
hey
i didn't want this anymore i changed my
mind period
nobody has to take the blame mike since
natalie left the house
have you been seeing anyone else oh it's
about to get real
lou since she left the house you haven't
look at that smile on natalie's face
natalie
have you been
with anyone
no dates no with anyone
hanging out with anybody oh there's a
girl just with girls who was the guy you
were with in new orleans jovi
oh
oh
[Music]
it wasn't mike what you saw natalie with
the guy yeah
what makes me think he's not gay for
example she tried it it didn't look good
to me jovi went on to explain that
natalie came to new orleans and she met
up with him and yara for dinner with her
plus one it was just really a good
lawyer this news took mike by surprise
but natalie claims that she only took
this mystery man to dinner because she
didn't want to meet up with jovi and
yara alone where did you meet him
it's a communication community stuff
people
okay he's russia yeah it's not a lot of
people i met from the russian community
you just you just find random guys in
new orleans to go
you don't want to be a third wheel
oh
yara did you get the impression that
there was anything going on between
natalie and this guy that she brought to
dinner i asked her if they together but
there was no clear answer like in
natalie's way
i don't understand that's why i cannot
tell nothing because i don't know
clearly why is she laughing that's the
laugh if i got caught and why would you
bring a new man to dinner with your
other 90 day castmates you look too
faced i agree julia it comes off as if
she was trying to disrespect mike or
that this was another game she decided
to play i mean y'all are separated so do
what you do but
common sense just says keep it out of
the 90 day family
that was unnecessary so practically if i
sit next to someone what if i sleep with
this person it's bull you know no one
said you slept with him natalie
you know anyway that decision she made
is going to cost her literally because
after mike heard this news he decided to
make some necessary changes
oh yeah this is the moment i told you to
keep in mind earlier
don't let your jaw stay on the floor for
too long yeah who pay for you live right
now how you live you're not working now
legal you not have money how you live
right now without mike mike support you
for you pay for apartment for clothes
for food you pay for yourself that's for
you
i know the answer
me too
yes she has she has my bank card okay
still to this day michael youngquist
yes i just used his full government name
because these are the type of actions
that make you not feel bad for him
why does she still have his card did she
buy that dress with this card
it's real nice
why you just blocked her from the card
yeah i would after i leave today you are
blocked from the card i am deactivating
that card i wonder did he do it mike is
too nice and a part of me understands
because i can be too nice at times as
well but
how long are you going to try to see the
good in someone when they keep showing
you the bad there is no reason natalie
should have his card especially now that
she's living in florida and he doesn't
even know where or with who
but
as a matter of fact i don't even know if
i believe that because you can look at
your bank statement and see where she's
spending money and mike if i were you
out of five foot divorce a long time ago
plan on filing we're not planning on
filing for divorce
yeah
i'm not gonna scream and say i will not
give you divorce i cannot because i want
you to be happier
if you think it's you can find better
woman than me and be happy i will only
pray for you honestly i'm not sure if
michael wants those prayers after this
conversation everyone got up and a
producer backstage asked mike if there
is any chance for reconciliation between
him and natalie
just listen to what he says i mean i
don't
know who knows down the road maybe she
just needs to go get everything out of
her system and uh go live her dreams and
stuff there's nothing wrong with that
you know i applaud her for it but i'm
not gonna wait around forever but what
does she come to america for her dreams
or you it seems like mike is so busy
trying to save natalie and she doesn't
want to be saved
i know myself i'm a good person but
i'm tired to fight
so i don't care i don't give he has to
fall for divorce and i will say okay and
we just bought
[Music]
there is no way for me to stay if he
falls on yours
i don't know what to say anymore mike's
mom also made an appearance and nothing
major happened there other than the fact
that she told natalie once again that
she didn't call her a hooker honestly i
don't i swear
i did not call you a hooker but
there was a moment where angela pretty
much said what everyone was thinking
when it comes to natalie i'm sick of
hearing her be the victim man
if you don't like mike mike don't want
to text your ass home
it seems like angela bottled up all of
our frustration into one sentence take
your
ass home it was aggressive but honest i
lost 20 more pounds in the last two
months and have hit my goal weight all
right since we're discussing angela
let's move on to her breakdown on set
here we come [ __ ] hold your husbands
she said hold your husbands
angela oh my god look at that girl
oh just wait kalani she's gonna give you
a real nice view in just a minute angela
was filling herself in this hot red
jumpsuit she even gave us a little
stretch before she revealed that she
lost 106 pounds 160
pounds
wow
okay she also revealed that she got her
boobs redone a week ago to make them
bigger after she had a breast reduction
earlier this season he started
complaining making fun of me and my hair
too small look how do you laugh michael
your babies are smiling he'd make fun
and make fun so i said well you know
what i'll go get some put in smart ass
and according to angela michael had no
problem with that particular surgery
overall i'm just happy she's healthy
because all these surgeries and smoking
cigarettes right after her procedures
have been a huge risk that was very
painful
all right let's get into the drama
angela got emotional when recalling how
michael treated her after her surgeries
but he continued to say how he was sorry
i really thought i was gonna die
like really i'm sorry okay
after angela pulled herself together dr
obang the doctor who performed her
breast reduction surgery came up and you
know angela loves to make michael
jealous with the dr obang now angela
have you only seen
dr obang
at the office i also know
i went to his birthday party
in california you were never alone with
dr obang
my producer is telling me
that he drove you home
now this is no shade
but why are they trying to play like
angela and dr obang could potentially
have something going on
like really why are y'all trying to do
that are you kidding me
there's nothing angela explained that a
week ago she went to a bar with dr obang
her daughter skyla and a few other
people she started feeling sick and he
offered to take her home but michael was
pissed because if he was in that
position and he didn't relay that
information to her
she would have blown up i know you you
if i go out you ask what what would i do
every goddamn details but you now you oh
yeah you do darn it buddy
no don't tell me
tony buddy
[Music]
dr wayne's a very very caring man and
you need to learn something from him
then
well thank you for the approval now
enters michael's aunt lydia who gave her
two cents on angela's new look
i knew luke is okay
she looked very
sexy according to what she said she's
pretty okay
oh jesus christ well the conversation
was going pretty okay until the topic of
michael having a baby came up so can you
accept the fact that she cannot have a
child
and no problem with that but we talked
about surrogate's mother which she
agreed late lydia you started your
business i've heard you keep putting me
finger at me at this point angela took
this argument from about 20
to 100 just like that mind your voice
yeah
business you don't talk to me
business or you can go and i'll go right
again with dr obama [ __ ]
you better respect me you mind your own
business
tell my husband what to
do these brand new puppies what's all
these now how do you like that now
you want to listen to her i'll show up
everybody in your mind
and
you too michael
you won't see them goddamn again
you too
angela knows how to put on a show
like her or not how do you like that no
she knows what she's doing when it comes
to reality tv
look at jovi he was thoroughly
entertained
all right before i go tiffany announced
that she's getting weight loss surgery
i'm getting the same surgery that angela
got you are in two days her husband
ronald was against it at first why don't
put in the work that's that's my
mindset to it
you'll appreciate the results much more
but she says she feels like this is
what's best for her it's not going to be
easy it's going to be really hard
because the surgery changes the food you
can take but it doesn't change your mind
so
that's the work that needs to be done
after the surgery next week on part two
of the tell-all it's asuelu kalani
andrei and libby's turn in the hot seat
he pushed me out and my mom he did not
put his hands on him
outside i'm choosing what is right you
guys don't really disrespect no matter
what you fight but never push your mama
it's your mama i'm mad
and there's gonna be problems
we have charlie in the studio today
hello
oh you getting my face i'm flapping
straight away those guys all right 90
day fans fam make sure you stick with
e.t because we are covering it all i
will see you next time
[Music]